Matthew let's talk about it all you are
dubbed hot Jesus on this show can you
turn it aside can we see your great long
hair in the man bun there it is oh there
it is
were you ever called Jesus before the
show or did this nickname come out of
too hot to handle actually I get it a
lot I get it a lot you have the tattoo
too right I do yeah the cross and a
Bible verse on the other side okay so
you're Christian I am yeah
okay so I I gotta ask you because a lot
of Christian people would maybe say wait
a minute you're this Christian guy and
you went on this show that's all about
hooking up with people help them
understand that part of your faith and
how you went on a show that seemed to be
or at least you guys seem to be under
the impression that it was all about
hookups
well there's a lot to that question hey
I had no idea what show I was getting it
was definitely a surprise but B I would
say just because you have any sort of
religious background or connection to
any religion at all doesn't mean you're
perfect we're all humans and see I'm a
dude in my you know I'm young so I have
a very strong sex drive I'm not ashamed
of that at all and I don't know I feel
like that's a common misunderstanding
just because you're a Christian doesn't
mean that you're not horny yeah right
it's no judgement at all it's just I
think there are a lot of people in
America who have sort of you know an
idea of a typical view and I thought a
lot of the things that you had to say
we're really interesting you came onto
the show and said look I'm not even
somebody who necessarily believes in
marriage or monogamy I think you make a
comment about maybe you'd have a kid
with a woman of a different race or or
nationality from all over the world yeah
I just I'm trying to spread my seed I'm
kidding I'm kidding
I'm I'm playing the numbers you know I
want my bloodline to last no I I I don't
I said I do believe in love I just think
that it is more rare than the common
public likes to believe you know and so
I'd rather be surprised by a good thing
than disappointed with the bad thing so
I try to set my expectations a bit lower
and then see where it goes from there
so what kind of show did you think you
were signing up for because in the
casting process you guys were asked a
lot of questions about your sex lives
right yeah yeah when you put it that way
I feel pretty dumb but I just I kind of
I'm an open book and so when you go
through a casting process they're just
trying to get to know you and so they've
not asked questions and I wasn't really
trying to find a pattern I knew there
was some sort of dating element to it so
I was just saying hey this is who I am
and this is what I feel and this is what
I think and now in hindsight I'm like
okay I really understand why I made the
cast you became the sex cop did you
think you would become that role no no I
didn't know I did not expect that but
I'm happy that that was my role I'm the
oldest guy that was there so I felt like
it was fitting so you you leave what
made you make that decision I basically
I just kind of like the last day I had
just met some new contest's there new
new people and I was kind of holding on
to that last bit that maybe there was
someone that would be coming in that I
found attractive and could test myself
more in that way
and there just wasn't so I was like you
know I can selfishly decide to stay or I
can make the mature decision to leave
and I also thought there's a great value
in my absence because it would allow
some of the other guys that I was kind
of overseeing to be able to kind of
either own as you said a sex kapolei
what can people do when
I'm not there looking over their
shoulder which I think he's also really
fitting with the Jesus thing because I
don't know if they said show this or not
but I did say as I left like shrugs like
what are we gonna do and I said well as
the story goes Jesus does leave so like
you guys can figure it out I love that
that's a chicken way of putting it um so
you you leave ultimately everybody got
$7,500 any regrets about leaving do you
think you should have stayed or wish you
had no no I mean it would have been like
it would have been a selfish decision
purely out of the desire to have like a
paycheck to stay it was in everyone's
best interest like mine and everyone
else's that I left and I came from like
a loving place